uh good morning everybody and welcome to
this extraordinary meeting of teambridge
District Council
um just before we go to the agenda of
some protocol announcements
um no fire alarm test is planned today
so should the fire alarm sound please
leave the room by the nearest exit and
meet by the stand at the far end of the
car park
during the debate if you wish to speak
please raise your hand and a boom
microphone will be brought over to you
if you don't speak into the microphone
you will not be heard on the live stream
and please remain seated while speaking
please keep your points short and I ask
members not to repeat points that have
already been raised and voting will be
by a show of hands
should the meeting be adjourned for any
reason any filming must cease unless the
express permission from those being
filmed has been obtained and during any
adjournment I would ask that members
public and officers please leave the
room until the meeting reconvenes
so moving forward onto our agenda agenda
item one is apologies for absence do we
have apologies have apologies from
councilor Evans Hocking because well
Jeffries Morgan Jay petherick
Thorne tomb h Cox Eden and Phipps
thank you that's noted
um
item two are there any Declarations of
Interest
I see
is that counselor patch
thank you
I'll ask um
people attending here members and the
public to bear with me this might be
slightly longer than the typical
Declaration of interest but I do have
quite substantial interest to declare
who I must declare first will I believe
to be a non-registerable financial
interest
and that is primarily a debt owed by me
towards this Council
for in the region of 8 000 pounds costs
awarded to this Council in civil
litigation that I took against them
this is similar litigation concerning a
standards case that was brought against
me
this action was defended by team
District Council
by means that included misleading the
high court and failing in their duty of
Candor towards the high court
associated with this debt to the council
the council is currently deducting my
allowance at source
now also associated with those financial
interests
I have been on the receiving end of
ongoing threats of bankruptcy
proceedings against me from this
acting on behalf of the council
I was also recently
just before Christmas actually served
with a court order
by Mr
on behalf of this Council to attend
court for questioning
regarding my financial circumstances
under threat of prison time if I did not
attend this was despite me having
cooperated 100 percent with the
council's questions regarding my
financial situation and my ability to
pay and the speed at which I might pay
their debts
incidentally having made arrangements to
travel to court they then withdrew this
though not not after my having spent
Christmas
worrying about this threat of prison
that was hanging over me thanks
someone who I think is deeply
compromised to this Council
now
I understand from the Constitution
that it's possible for me to have a
dispensation
to stay in the council for this meeting
I would not want to stay in this meeting
if it should ever get around to
discussing directly the issue of the
debt against me and remedial in right of
the wrongdoing of in like the wrongdoing
of this Council against me I would like
to leave the council then however I
would like to stay and take part in
debate about the main issue and indeed I
have submitted a report to this Council
on item three on the agenda which if I'm
not to be here I would quite like
someone else to present to this um
Council so I would like to request a
dispensation to stay in this Council
for the for this meeting now there's a
problem here isn't there really because
if we look at who I might seek advice
as or a dispensation to stay in this
meeting
who has a severe conflict of interest in
a sense that he has an interest in me
not staying in this meeting not
participating fully in this meeting
um in that that um he's written a report
which has recommended this Council not
discuss fully the ombudsman's findings
of systemic problems at this Council but
instead send it to the standards
committee
so in other words send findings
of of a failed and discredited standards
regime standards committee to the
standards committee to remedy
of course that serves his interest in
his role in my case not not being
discussed publicly by this full Council
because I have no doubt that if the
standard if the stands committee were to
discuss this it would be behind closed
doors
so who who was able to give me legal
advice without a conflict of interest on
whether I might stay in this meeting
is there anyone here
um
and and of course this issue of who is
able to advise me about a conflict of
interest themselves in having the Deep
problems that this Council particularly
in its standards regime brought to light
um I I see we we do not have
yeah
um
but but I I think the whole Council in a
sense has a conflict of interest in me
not taking part in this meeting and me
not not presenting my report and me not
voicing my concerns and setting out the
evidence I think I think that to the
leader of this Council
self is involved in my case as all
members know I've circulated a report
setting out the evidence of the wrongs
done Against Me by this various parties
I'm really I lost know who can advise me
on whether I can stay in this meeting
uh now I'm just I'm just wrapping up now
these are important matters I have no
duty to present my my interests at this
and and have decided whether I can stay
here and I remind that I'm sure he needs
no reminding that um I'm sure he studied
the constitution on his duties as chair
of the council number one is to be the
the conscience of this Council I think
something that's sorely lacking and
sorely needed a good conscience that is
now I'd also be looking forward to
hearing Declarations of interest of
others on this council members and
officers senior officers they might not
might not have direct Financial
interests in this meeting
but by God they have reputational
interest in this meeting if the truth
comes to light if the public hears
what's been going on in this Council
that's the end for them
incidentally I believe look in this
report making a recommendation which is
unlawful making it a lawful
recommendation I think his report to
this Council constitutes under the
office's code of conduct grounds for
summary Council
began speaking in order to say something
and you've been shouted down by the
counselor as a point of order that is
not acceptable
thank you councilor Swain councilor
patch could you confine your comments
please to a declaration of Interest okay
and that is up to you to decide not
anybody else only you can say whether
you have a declaration of Interest okay
I will end my Declaration of Interest
with reference to the the letter of
complaint
that was sent to this Council that led
to the standards case against me
this letter of complaint included
complaints that implicated
and how is how is that a declaration of
this is the definition of interest
because these are things in my report
that I wish to present which I will
probably not be able to present once
I've I've had a ruling on my
dispensation and that letter of
complaint also
um
was was something that was sent to
council leader of this Council that he
discussed with count with um
before sending to
to
um to construct the case against me
while ignoring all other complaints
against those parties and of systemic
failure at this Council
I'm wrapping up now I'm wrapping up
chair just just it will take me less
than a minute now this letter which um
team bridge legal council presented to
the high court
um
so there's evidence to high court
um suggests that um the the the leader
of this council did indeed
um receive this letter and discuss it
with
um I I've got an email trail from this
Council in an information release which
shows a solicitor for the complainant
sending this letter of complaint to
councilor con it and yet at my standards
case when I wish to bring up this letter
of complaint as defense in my standards
case I got a very I asked a simple
question of Mr Connor whether he'd seen
this letter and this was his reply
a simple question has
in the letter of complaint that
initiated this case against
in that life
councilor patch you're about to hear the
lead of the council lying at my
standards heating but that has nothing
that has nothing to do with the
Declaration of Interest well it is it's
my interest it that the topic of this
meeting is properly discussed openly
counselor patch
you asked for a dispensation does it
request for dispensation must be
submitted in writing before the meeting
can only be responded to in writing and
can you I wasn't aware of that to be
honest having looked at the um code of
conduct from Members this morning can
you point me to the provision in the
code of conduct that says
don't think that's appropriate at the
moment
I think it is really because you you are
the conscience of the council you must
apply the rules of the council you're
telling me something which I patiently
to believe to be untrue
I will ask the monitoring officer to to
make reference to the where in the
Constitution that that is stated point
of order chair
um
has a severe conflict of interest in me
not attending this meeting and not
voicing my concern to this meeting
indeed me not presenting my report at
this meeting and the procedure for for
seeking dispensation is set out in the
localism ACT not in our constitution
okay well I think we're Bound by our
constitution uh with the localism ACT
says that we have to have a constitution
I don't believe it sets out um those
specific requirements um in any case
has just compromised himself yet again
by acting with a conflict of interest in
order to deny an elected representative
of the people right in this meeting
that's an allegation that has no
substance it's a fact it's a fact
I would disagree
um we you are the conscience of this
Council act like it
this Council has for so long been
digging a hole for itself in the gutter
and is finally concept into the sewers
where it is floundering in its own
excrement
that is that is that is not acceptable
true though it is
I'd like I'd like I'd like a ruling by a
legal officer a legal representative of
this Council who is not conflicted with
an interest on whether I might have a
dispensation
dispensation is it that has to be
submitted in writing no it doesn't
referring me point of order refer me to
that provision that's not a point of
order that is actually it is a point of
order it can refer to points of law or
points of Constitution
can you indicate the rule uh
the point of order May relate only to an
alleged breach of the council's rules of
procedure
can you tell me which procedure or which
law has been broken now that you you
need a point of order no you're the one
who's telling me I'm telling you the
Constitution is being broken by you
saying that I need to submit something
in writing you shown with a law that
says I need to present something in
writing
I I think we would
not here from on this matter any further
and go to the vote isn't that isn't that
something that needs to be put to the
council to vote on whether or not be
heard I know this because I've had a
vote that I not be heard before or
wrongdoing at this Council when the vast
majority of these members voted thank
you cancel the patch councilor Swain
I would like to Second your motion let
this be no further heard okay thank you
no further heard on this matter thank
you
sorry
I'm still awaiting I'm still awaiting I
I know I can't be heard but I'm still
awaiting a ruling on my expectation we
should now go to the vote those in which
vote
the vote that you should no longer be
heard those in favor please raise your
heart I would like to request a named
vote on this would anybody like to stand
and support that
so we have a named vote
so ask treasure to do the Roll Call
so those in favor
of the councilor Pat should no not no
further be heard on this matter
thank you chair councilor Austin
councilor Bradford against
the relevant
councilor colclough councilor con it or
councilor David Cox
cuts the doors
cancer Dewhurst
councilor foden
councilor Goodman Bradbury
councilor Gribble
councilor Haynes councilor Hayes
councilor Gordon hook councilor Jackie
hook councilor Jeffrey
cancer Jenks
cancer Keeling
councilor McGregor
thanks
counselor Malone
Council Nutley or
councilor Parker
that's a patch
I think you'll find I have a conflict of
interest in voting on this so I won't
vote
cancer person or Council rollerson or
Council Russell
Council Swain
Council Taylor
cancer Wiggly cats are Nuttall a four
cancer Clarence
that's Carriage thank you
any other Declaration of Interest comes
from McGregor
oh ciao
say I think then I'm not allowed to
speak on the matter I'm not allowed to
speak on the matter yeah
best as I left or am I able to sit in
and watch what's going on
that's up to you councilor patch
councilor McGregor
thank you chair
um I just wanted to welcome you back
um glad to see you at the meeting today
however I do want to bring up a matter
of concern uh to me which I think there
is a conflict of interest
um for the chair which is yourself
because you are or have been a member of
the standards committee that has been
part of the report I think there's also
a conflict of interest having the legal
advice coming from
who is the subject of part of the report
and I think that um members of the
standards committee past and present
within the last four years should be
considering their position as a conflict
of interest and I don't believe
should be providing any legal advice on
this matter bearing in mind the nature
of the report thank you chair uh thank
you councilman
the subject of the report it was the
previous
so if we can move then to item three on
the agenda
sorry I beg a pardon cancer do was I
didn't see your hand sorry
is this a declaration of Interest cancel
the drawers
yes it's a yes it's a declaration of
interest and then it will be followed by
a point of order
the Declaration of interest is that
clearly this meeting has been brought
about about a complaint I brought
forward against the council uh which was
uh as you noted under the uh advice of
and uh
who sat in on my standards hearing
uh the case was uh was defended by
who spent uh three years uh suggesting
the council had done nothing wrong uh
and that the local government Ombudsman
had no jurisdiction and no uh oversight
on this case so the point of order is
that
does have a full and uh robust conflict
of interest my Declaration of interest
is that I am party to this report uh but
given the uh the
the endurance of of the last three years
and and uh the ordeal that I've been put
through uh and given the words of
Michael King Obe the local government
Ombudsman uh the local councilors have a
key role in scrutinizing their
Authority's actions enough and then
hunts right of freedom of speech to us
what might appear uh uncomfortable
questions at times then I propose to
continue to partake in this debate and I
think the council should look very
heavily on its decision to silence uh
those uncomfortable questions they will
be looked very dimly on uh in a court of
law thank you thank you Council just to
remind you that this is a declaration of
Interest not a debate of the context I
was putting forward a point of order and
the Declaration of Interest I think I
was very clear about that
I I don't believe that to be a point of
order
we will move on to item three of the
agenda and that is the consideration of
the report by the local government
social care Ombudsman with reference
number
21004 645 and I'll ask the leader to
introduce and move recommendations
thank you chairman
I restate the apology I sent to
councilor doors on the 19th of January
as leader of the council I apologize to
councilor Jaws without reservation for
the manner in which the council handed
the standards complaints process
I am sorry both for the manner in which
the council dealt with the matter and
also for the distress and upset cause to
him
I also apologize to the council that as
the Ombudsman found there were a series
of faults in the council's processes and
in how the investigation subsequently
unfolded
I accept the ombudsman's report in full
and all of its recommendations I believe
the council should also accept the
report and recommendations of the
Ombudsman and I propose the following
chairman
I propose that we delete the
recommendations one to three of the
report issued with the council meeting
and insert new recommendations and I
have copies of these for distribution
because there are a number of them
chairman but they are I believe
comprehensive
the recommendations are
the council notes and accepts without
reservation the content and
recommendations of the ombudsman's
report and agrees one
the council apologizes to cancel the
doors noting and accepting the apology
presented by the leader on the 19th of
January and renewed at today's meeting
two
to rescind and remove the decision
notice dated 22 July 2020 replacing it
with a statement stating the notice has
been withdrawn following an
investigation and provide a link to the
ombudsman's report
three
that the managing director on behalf of
the council apologizes to councilor
Dawes within seven working days
four
that the managing director apologizes to
council for the matters identified by
the Ombudsman in the public interest
report
five
that the council refers its former
solicitor and monitoring officer and the
Ombudsman report to the solicitors
regulation Authority for consideration
6.
a robust program of training on
standards and the complaints process is
provided jointly for all councilors and
the senior management team within three
months of the new Council being
established this may
seven
a report is published within four weeks
in the members newsletter and on the
council website setting out how
procedures for receiving and processing
standards complaints have been updated
to comply with the recommendations of
the Ombudsman report
eight
any further procedural changes to put
into effect the umberton's
recommendations are conducted under the
oversight of the procedures committee
Council also believes the Ombudsman
Services interpretation of the localism
ACT may have an impact May sorry may
have an impact for all other local
authorities and is therefore a matter of
wider local government interest
the council's head of Legal Services
writes to the Secretary of State and the
local government Association seeking
further Clarity with regard to a whether
the Ombudsman has effectively created a
new appeal process and suggested
processes changes above that required by
legislation
B the role of the Ombudsman service
which has previously cancel the doors
complaint has subsequently declined to
consider councilors complaints about
standards
see the interpretation of a localism act
the Nolan principles and the
interrelationship with the Human Rights
Act and D the duty of councils to
protect employees from bullying
harassment and intimidation and finally
chairman the council issues a news
release to inform the public that the
actions agreed at this meeting chair
when these recommendations come to the
vote I ask for a recorded vote
and finally chairman the only purpose of
today's extraordinary council meeting
has set out in my request to the chair
is to consider the report and
recommendations of the Ombudsman and
such Rec action as is necessary to
direct the implementation of those
recommendations thank you chairman
thank you councilman the consequences
moved recommendations which have been
seconded by councilor duhurst so it is
now open for debate councilor Keeling
thank you very much Mr chair
I first would like to be associated with
the leaders comments
Mr chairman I apologize as the past
chair of Standards to councilor Richard
Dawes for the process of the hearing
I was assured by the then
not only prior to the hearing but when
we reflected during the hearing
I was always assured
that the standards committee was
following the model code of process and
there had been complaints
to sorry
to seek and investigating officer who
was independent
has let councilor Doors Down
and the standards committee
Mr chairman I believe our present
has already made changes to address
concerns of the Ombudsman thank you Mr
chairman
thank you councilor Keeling
there'll be no further hands we have the
recommendations
sorry cancel the doors
hello thank you
um I know the apology from uh from
councilor Connor and uh it it is uh full
and unreserved it doesn't match the
apology that was put out by the council
to the Press on the 19th of January
uh that apology uh stated we are
disappointed that the Ombudsman
concluded
uh that contrary to what we believed at
the time our stuff did not follow the
correct procedures
that uh
that
it went on to suggest that there was a
problem
in terms of counselor behavior that the
council needs to protect its officers it
did not reflect the the essence of the
uh the ombudsman's report I would ask
this Council uh I've asked already this
Council who wrote that uh
that press release
um I noticed was withdrawn but it was
reported by the BBC by The Herald
Express by the mid Devon Advertiser so
the footprint of the council's apology
is set with with a very unsatisfactory
non-apology
so I would like the council to make an
official withdrawal of that uh and the
public one
um I note at the time uh when uh the
standards procedures were found against
myself and councilor Malone that letters
were written to the mid Devon Advertiser
and the local press that was signed by
multiple people signed by the lead
former leader current leader of the
council Deputy leader chair of Standards
chair of the council so I would expect
any public facing apology to be signed
by all those parties
um I know to councilor keeling's apology
uh
it's a shame that that 0.6 of the
ombudsman's report wasn't taken on board
by by the chair of the standards
committee that throughout the whole
procedure I and councilor Malone told
him that they were breaking the law that
they were breaching the Human Rights Act
and that they were breaching their own
rules uh councilor Keeling confirmed to
me that he had read my report seven
times
he'd ready with the rebuttals in but
clearly not taking any of those on board
the
the uh
the thing uh that uh I note from the
recommendations put forward by councilor
Comet uh that follows through the
actions of the last three years is the
council's
disappointment in the ombudsmans
findings because it appears that within
your recommendations you're going to
write to the Secretary of State once
again questioning if this is any of the
business of the Ombudsman at all so
ultimately though you're offering a full
apology uh you seem to be suggesting
that uh that the jurisdiction should not
exist
I think the Ombudsman made very clear on
multiple occasions
that they had Authority they were I'm
not an employee of this Council my
reputation has been trashed
damaged
and uh and and smeared over a three-year
period and the council took no care or
consideration of their actions they
ignored the fact that they had been told
they'd broken the law and they continued
to smear me in in in in public
statements that were made by this
Council councilors in this room are
still doing it today
um
and uh it it it smarts really if if you
put forward an apology and and within
the same motion again want to question
whether the Ombudsman actually has any
authority to give oversight uh to this
Council
what
my case
suggests in fact demonstrates very
clearly
is that there are systemic failings
within the standards procedures at this
Council none more clearly outlined than
those of the Injustice that was dealt
out to cancel X councilor Liam Malone
who was tied up with me in in an
investigation
had the same procedures and processes
put forward uh against him and the same
the same decision so I would move to add
an amendment uh to the motion that the
apology should be extended to councilor
Liam Malone who uh suffered the same
injustices from as the council has just
pointed out a solicitor who they are
referring to the SRA for uh oversight uh
for from a professional body therefore
the
um the outcome of that standards
procedure must be seen by this Council
as unsafe
I would also then go further
that given the uh details that were
provided in my report that I've sent to
council for this meeting but can be
reviewed at any given juncture indeed
that there are serious failings within
the standards procedure throughout the
last five years under the under the
control
uh when the Ombudsman in their report
pointed out failures what they actually
are talking about are male
administrations when you pilot male
administrations it doesn't take a great
deal of time to get to a point that this
council is guilty of some very serious
uh failings that would constitute
misconduct in public office or
misfeasons in public office those are
incredibly serious criminal offenses
that carry jail terms for the
perpetrators of those crimes so I think
this Council needs to think very heavily
and uh and and consider its position
as it moves forwards and gives the
oversight that it doesn't continue its
pattern of behavior and and and attempt
to style out uh what is undoubtedly one
of the most
stinging reports ever delivered by an
ombudsman that names myself only done in
three percent of complaints when it is
in the public interest
so so the the council need need to have
some proper and thorough oversights I
know I know most of the people involved
in this uh sailing off into the sunset
but their their actions have a lasting
effect on on this district and if this
Council cannot have the correct
oversight on on its own failings then
then then it it will be held to account
through other routes but it but first it
has first it has its own opportunity to
set its housing order so I I'm I'm
proposing that um
that we add to uh the an amendment to
The Proposal that councilor Malone
receives the same apologies that I
receive and the other standards
procedures that were carried out by uh
under the auspice of a
who has been referred to the SRA uh that
they be seen as unsafe thank you
[Applause]
has moved a proposal that the apology be
extended to cancel them alone is that
seconded can we go to the vote on that
please
councilor Olson
Council has counselor Malone asked to be
apologized to is he aware that he'll be
linked with this report because his name
hasn't been mentioned in it he hasn't it
to be certain I was appointed you know
respect for other people isn't it
uh councilor alone do you wish to
respond
um
good or submitted a complaint to the lgo
um I didn't because I thought the forces
ranged against me in doing so were just
too massive and I just didn't have time
I've got three children two of them have
special needs
um what counselor Dawes has managed to
do as a testament to his tenacity and uh
proof that if you bang away hard enough
the light will eventually get in uh had
I wish I wish I had put in the report to
the lto because
God knows the things that were found in
favor of counselor doors that applied to
me I I always had up by the standards uh
committee for things that I published on
a website months before I even thought
about being a counselor in fact I only
became a counselor because someone in
the lib Dem said if you can do better
why don't you join the council so I did
it's all on you actually Jackie hook so
that's why I'm here but God's sake
having having the human rights abuses
that apply to councilor doors they apply
in some cases tenfold to me I mean it it
was ridiculous it was ridiculous
what also what it also was different is
that in my standards committee it
answered the councilor rollerson are you
prepared to have the apology to include
you
that was emotion and I'm allowed to
speak to it
if I'm if I'm to say yes I think it
should extend to me I should probably
explain why I think that's the case
in my standards hearing unlike in
Council of doors there was an
independent person called
and he tried time and time again
to tell the committee that they were
infringing on my right of free speech he
tried and he tried he was ignored and
ignored by people who don't understand
the law
by people who don't understand procedure
by people who were just there to
drummers into the ground I'm talking to
you Linda pedrick
I don't think this is the right time for
a long speechless you asked were you
prepared this is exactly the time for a
long speech
point
let me speak for a moment
please do not use abusive language
counselor Malone because at every point
this was fought against do I'll take you
to a a full Council several several four
councils ago when councilor Swain asked
the orchestrated question oh I I
apparently councilor Maloney thinks his
human rights have been infringed has any
research been done on that and and Oh
Yes actually it has and nothing no such
thing has happened all the way through
you continued to to set up these
pathetic little question and answer
sessions to carry on putting the boot
into me to carry on putting the boot
into councilor doors and you conflated
both of our cases all the way through
your treatment has been appalling I've
had threats against my family made by
who who quoted who quoted our standards
cases that were meant to be confidential
he knew the dates he knew the charges he
taunted us with them
on social media he phoned me up over and
over at midnight and this is all because
of what you have done so yes I would
like an apology thank you thank you
Council
patch
lies this Council indulged in in
stitching we are
councilor Patrick councilor McGregor
thank you chair
um it's a very interesting word to use
or a phrase to use systemic failures
um the lgo
clearly felt that there was a
significant case to answer for Council
of doors and also mentioning Council
Malone but those systemic failures
should come at no surprise to a council
that has delivered
um what what on the face of it and I am
going to use the term bullying outcomes
and bias outcomes particularly around
those who are not within a certain group
I'll give you for instance the lgo
found against the council and the
previous
in the case of a resident
that Resident laid a complaint at the
council's door that they had dismissed
his complaint against the counselor
sitting in this chamber currently
um
as what was the word that they used it
was vexatious but had no no basis for
making that complaint particularly as
the resident was making a complaint
about that particular counselor having
failed
under its Duty
as outlying body Ico
to deliver all of the emails now that
counselor was never pursued never
punished never taken through a standards
hearing
that was a serious breach of conduct on
the part of that councilor as serious
breach of conduct on the part of the
previous
so it dates back to even before 2019
when this Council changed iteration
and the apologies I would extend the
apology to councilor David Cox on the
way he was treated
a very clear case of coaching of a
complainant by a counselor in this
chamber
and the pursuit of counselor Cox was
actually decided and the and the
decision was made on the basis that
when asked what was the basis of
evidence said oh it was in the paper so
that's the basis of the evidence to be
already been dealt with and yet there
was actual evidence from a charity in
the form of a statement from that
charity the councilor Cox was acting as
a trustee of a charity not as a
counselor so in that fact I think that
should be
dismissed and corrected online I think
councilor Eden isn't disputing that she
swore
but she was treated very very
differently markedly differently from a
man who had a reputation for bullying
who admitted the bullying in the paper
funnily enough and yet when that was
discussed he was found not to breach the
code of conduct and in the very same
breath
Alison was found to have breached the
code of conduct now the situation in
that that environment in the reports for
those it stated that councilor Eden
felt stress and fear
the Town Council it's not the not the
district council the Town Council code
of conduct said that members should not
cause other members stress and fear and
yet that particular counselor who caused
the stress of fear was found not to
breach the code of conduct
so very clear marked difference in the
way that people are treated
excuse me chair um I'm getting as the
seconder to the motion I am entitled to
make a speech and I can hear grumblings
from the from from people who seem to
think that this is unfair that I'm
allowed to make this speech
um my my position on this is that all
should be all of the the decisions in
the last four to five years should be
resolved appropriately now whilst
Council Regan is not making uh a
complaint about her particular finding
because she did admit that she swore at
councilor Matthews on the day in the
Town Council
the write-up afterwards caused her
significant harm reputational harm
because it was contradictory and she did
approach and it's the response from
and the standards committee was nothing
short of dismissive
and that unfortunately speaks to a it
speaks to the foundations of systemic
failures within the council on the
process of standards
councilor Malone and Council doors have
stated their case councilor patches
stated his case quite valuably this
morning but I think there is a good case
for all of those standards uh decisions
to be reviewed and where appropriate
corrections made decision notices taken
down and explanations put in place
uh and I think that's a a valuable
outcome for this Council to rectify
issues that it has there are clear
systemic failings in this Council there
it would be quite easy for members of
the public to draw conclusions that if
you step out of line you will be
punished
counselors are supposed to work without
fear or favor that is the key element of
being a counselor in this chamber
if we can't work without fear or favor
then we should not be here
and I think it's really important that
this Council rectifies all of the
injustices that have been inflicted on
all other councilors
since then it might be more difficult
with councilor patch because that has
this been the subject and is continuing
subject of legal uh interactions but the
rest should be done on the matter of
appeals second Appeals
let counselor Connor brought up uh that
the lgo is introducing an appeal process
Lord Evans of waredale said for serious
breaches there should be an appeals
process within standards that was
submitted to government on the on in
June or July 2019 as best practice
best practice is a matter which I have
repeated to this Council for the last
four years
it's not good enough that we are
dismissed repeatedly for bringing points
of order and questions to the council
that that are actually designed to help
the council improve its processes
because some of them are seen as being
from troublemakers within the council
and again that is working without fear
or favor
and even Council Eden if you recall
suggested some really really excellent
changes that were dismissed out of hand
the big problem that we've got is people
don't like change I get that
but when appeals are made to the uh
employment it is the equality
um
and Human Rights Commission and their
advisors the EAS
and they advise that counselors have
been treated
unfairly and perhaps unlawfully and that
is then also dismissed that is a serious
problem
these are experts in their field and I
would question as I did at the
appointment of the current
the expertise that is available to this
Council for understanding a employment
law B the equality act and see how that
is applied
no evidence has come to light so far
understands the equality act in any way
no indication that
had any understanding of the equality
act in fact one of them I would go as
far to say as they had difficulties with
the English language
the current independent persons they
look a very much better bet than the
previous ones and I think we should be
ensuring that the complaint goes to the
appropriate independent person based on
their skills and experience and I would
hope that we have at least one
who is an understanding of the equality
act and employment law
but anyway I'm going to finish there my
recommendation is that
we second the process of
rectifying all of the injustices over
the last four years thank you chair
thank you councilman McGregor um
I would like a response to which
response to somebody said about me by
the previous speaker
thank you point of correction and point
of response on a point made about me by
the previous speaker regarding the
situation of legal proceedings and in
particular this is related to the fact
that the council has not yet apologized
for misleading the high court uh that
the leader of this Council has not
apologized for misleading my standards
hearing oh put your hand down for a
minute and the chair of the standards
committee Linda pedrick has not
apologized for lying to me days before
my standard hearing and saying there was
okay I'll move to pointer correction the
status of my legal case is it's actually
ended it got to the European Court of
Human Rights and a single judge without
giving any and he's a reasoning said
that it did not fall within their remit
so that I'm afraid um that that's that
Avenue has gone for me
um a few other authorities remain
complaints to the police about
misconduct in public office by people
sat at this top table
complaints of conspiracy to commit
misconduct in public office including
people at the stop table yeah yeah go
ahead now
thank you
I would rely on councilor McGregor that
um recommendations seven and eight in in
councilor connets
um recommendations on which we we will
vote shortly is about how procedures for
receiving and processing standards
completely updated to comply with the
recommendations of the ombudsman's
report so I think the review that you
were asking for is going to happen
Canada did you wish to respond thank you
so this is the last speech
I'll come back to you in a moment
councilor swing voting remarks
I just simply wanted to respond to a
query that councilor Dawes raised
um
in when I spoke earlier nothing I said
was intended to diminish the apology I
presented
but the ombudsman's report does raise
wider matters of interest for the local
government family which is why I propose
the council wrote to the Secretary of
State and local government Association
for that Clarity some of which may
reflect on any proposals there are to
Amanda update the standards process
nationally
so I repeat for the voice of any doubt I
do not diminish by seeking to ask
government
to consider further the standards
process the apology I presented to
cancer doors
with regard to my recommendations to
cancer
because the apology has come from me and
my role as leader of the council
colleagues will recall that I
specifically included a recommendation
and a further apologist provided by the
managing director to councilor doors in
order to be sure that it is complete
that both the elected
part of the council and the officer part
of the council acknowledge the
ombudsman's report
in the ombudsman's report
he sets out
recommendations
and at 74 he says apologize to councilor
doors neglecting the findings of this
investigation which is what we have done
and are doing
and that we rescind the decision notice
of the 22nd July which is included in
the recommendations
and then in paragraph 75 a series of
further considerations is set out by the
Ombudsman which we also endorse Embrace
and want to accept and do the Ombudsman
does not make reference to any other
counselor any other decision of the
council any other standards matter and
and without being interrupted the issue
of this extraordinary meeting was called
solely to consider the ombudsman's
report and recommendations to council
chairman and so I resist the Amendments
made because the purpose of this meeting
is solely to consider the ombudsman's
report thank you chairman
councilor Swain
thank you
um colleagues we've heard quite a number
of Declarations of Interest today
um I think it's clear that this is a
matter that affects the whole Council
it's relevant to all of our office
officers
um and whilst it's important individuals
declare the Declaration of Interest I am
very pleased that everybody is still in
the room I think it's important that
this is an open process I seconded a
motion that councilor patch I seconded a
motion that councilor patch be no
further heard on this matter those were
the words that I
the chat
thank you councilor patch if you
remember the chair
proposed promotion and I seconded it as
I was saying I seconded a motion that
Council Apache be no further heard on
this matter the wording was quite
specific
um it was the matter of his own legal
proceedings against the council which
are not the subject of the ombudsman's
report or the subject of this meeting
systemic problems in the standards
regime cancel the patch please sit down
and please be silent
or I'll have to ask you to leave the
meeting
thank you
so I specifically seconded the motion
that perhaps not be heard on an issue
which was not relevant to this meeting
which is the ombudsman's report
and the associated findings
um
the umberton's report has found that the
council had systemic failings as our
colleagues have pointed out
um I think we all accept that you've
heard the apologies I agree uh
one of those failings was conflating the
actions of one counselor with those of
another this is mentioned in paragraph
uh
it's very important as the council has
now learned that we are very careful
about exactly what we're talking about
exactly what did happen
some of the actions that Council adores
were accused of were actually committed
by by councilor X as I understand the
report
this is important we need to be mindful
of it and it is important that we are
very clear about things being accurate
it's important therefore that we read
what the ombudsman's report actually
says and not what and not conflict that
with what we would like it to say
the ombudsman's reports findings both in
false and in uh
Corrections are all about the process
that was carried out during the
investigation uh nothing in the
ombudsman's findings is about the
actions that led to the investigation or
or other actions around that and that's
very important so when we hear words
like exonerated that is not the case at
the wording of the umberton support is
very clear it is all about the process
that was followed which was wrong and
the council has lessons to learn from
that
uh
Richard Dawes earlier uh came up with a
number of allegations of wrongdoing I
think if I remember correctly misleading
the high court was used
my apologies
thank you counselors you are sitting
behind me I apologize if I have
misattributed this is as we are all
agreed very important
I do not believe that
allegations of misleading the high court
are relevant to the ombudsman's
proceedings these are serious
allegations and should be looked at but
not in the context of shouting at people
in Council meetings which are about a
different subject it's not the right
place to investigate serious allegations
of wrongdoing
Richard Dawes I think it was but again
they are sitting behind me I apologize
if I'm quoting the wrong person said
that the council needs to protect its
officers
uh as though this is not the case
in fact this is the case again if we
read the ombudsman's report very
carefully it talks quite a lot about the
Human Rights Act and the enhanced right
to free speech which I'll be coming to
in a moment
um it talks about that but it
specifically says two things it says
that it that it has not
found anything about whether or not
Council adores human rights were
breached it does not comment on that
very specifically states that it's in
document on it and it also states that
the enhanced right to free speech is a
qualified right which must be weighed
against other rights including the
council's right to protect its officers
from bullying and harassment and
intimidation and uh inappropriate
pictures on Facebook
and exciting
and it has a duty and the chair has a
duty
please
there's a point point of order councilor
McGregor
point of order whilst I appreciate
councilor Swain's detailed uh speech
um and it is covering a lot of area it
is actually straying now into the
problems that led to the ombudsman's
report
um and I think it's really important
that we don't repeat smears that have
been made I don't I don't think smears
are being repeated and I'm sure
counselors Sweden will be very careful
to ensure that's the case
thank you councilman McGregor thank you
I was speaking about the council's duty
to protect its officers from bullying
and harassment and intimidation
uh I also refer to the chair's duty to
keep the meeting in order
um this is particularly relevant because
uh recently an allegation was made which
councilor Malone I think it was but
again my apologies are sitting behind me
uh pointed out where it was claimed that
human rights were being breached because
the chair had interrupted a counselor
during a meeting
um I think this is very important I
think human rights are very important I
spend a lot of my time fighting for them
uh
and so I took the step of seeking legal
advice about whether the human rights
were being breached and the response was
that they are not but I am summarizing
that was not the words used the response
which is I opened counselors questions
anyone can look it up the response was
very detailed and comprehensive and
explained the balance between the right
to free speech and other
responsibilities in very similar wording
in fact to the ones used by the
Ombudsman it is a balance
so let's be clear that this Council has
not there is no evidence that this
Council has breached anybody's human
rights what the Ombudsman criticized was
that
what if this what this report concluded
is that the council failed to pause to
consider the balance between human
rights
and the
processary
yeah sorry
clearly free speech in this case is
working one way and councilman wishes to
interrupt let's put the questions both
the Amendments and the recommendations
thank you
thank you chairman I was saying clearly
Council alone can't let others speak
let's just move to the that the
questions are put both the Amendments
and the recommendations
um
we are being shouted down
here we have a member a councilor patch
please sit down
um members I am going to adjourn this
meeting for 10 minutes please
um to take stock of of where we are and
what should come next
would you please turn off your camera
whilst we are in adjournment
you know
can we please reconvene
right the meeting is now reconvened
um cancer doubles I'm sorry councilor
Cox you had some sorry
you could you explain me the amendment
because I am I'm in favor including
councilor X
in the apology but I'm not
extended to all councilors
um they can they can individually write
to the um landable diving I have quite a
lot of people being counselor
um
[Music]
okay
Allison Edens um situation reading her
letters I feel she was treated
differently as a woman that's irrelevant
because this is about the omnisone
report but councilman appears councilor
X is
entangled in that and therefore I think
the apology should be identity so could
the amendment be read out I don't want
to support
a blanket apart and fall into it uh
thank you councilor Cox I was going to
ask councilor doors to clarify his
Amendment as I understand it Council
rules your amendment was that the
apology should be extended to include
cancer Malone is that correct
my uh
my amendment was to include councilman
for the exactly the reasons that uh to
cancel the cooks just pointed out that
he was conflated thank you thank you and
uh I I did want to come back to the
points that raised uh by councilor Swain
can I just finish clarifying your
Amendment council at all because it was
seconded by councilman McGregor who
added a further Amendment councilman
McGregor would you clarify that for us
please
I I wanted the apology extended to
counselor Malone uh and also in the
report that I submitted to this uh to
this meeting I alone I outlined serious
failings uh from 2018 and wanted all of
those uh findings to be deemed unsafe
that's what I actually said if you'd
like to rewind the tape
so my view is that we should now go to
the vote on the answer I would like to
come back to the points that were raised
by councilor Swain there were those are
not relevant to the amendment Council of
doors no but they're they they are
relevant because uh he he raised points
that that have been raised in the public
um in a public forum the uh uh further
defamed me as as the council has done
for for the last three years and I'd
just like to clarify
verification
well I'm going to read out what the
Ombudsman said when uh when I I think
councilor doors we should be going to
the vote
no I I I I don't think that's reasonable
I'll just go back and restate the local
councilors have a key role in
scrutinizing their authorities and have
an enhanced a right for freedom and
speech to ask at what times appear
uncomfortable questions now councilor
Swain raised some very uh I don't
understand why councilor Swain is able
to put forward things that define my
standing in my community and then and
then something like I don't even I don't
think and then sits there cutting his
clothes I do not suggestion has defamed
anybody well it doesn't matter for the
course
can we clarify the questions
uh
I ask
the chair of this Council having been
subject to three years of Injustice that
I am allowed to reply to councilor Swain
when he misquoted the ombudsman's report
Swain
you you I think
I don't know why you're asking councilor
Swain
um
if I just may interject here
your question was to counselor doors
regarding his Amendment yes right you're
asking councilor doors for Clarity on
that Amendment and he has clarified that
he his amendment was to extend the
apology to include councilor Malone okay
that's correct I think we should take a
vote
we should take a vote on that yeah and
there's a fact that there was a further
part to the amendment that all standards
hearing since 2018
be deemed to be unsafe due to the
systemic failings outlined by the local
government Ombudsman um Council of doors
I don't think that that part was
included yes the original Amendment yes
it was in yours yeah it was yeah
go to council at McGregor if he's prefer
to second that final
seconded yeah it seconded right we go to
the vote
a recorded vote Point avoid a chair I
just I I don't I don't think this
meeting is doing what it says on the tin
it's just not doing what it set out to
do you're supposed to be reviewing a
report that found systemic failings no
and what you're trying to do is ring
fence those failings
and you're throwing rocks
he's already been thrown overboard which
is very brave of you and I do agree she
was awful but you know the the
go sitting right there it's counting the
sways I was trying to say oh well this
isn't they didn't really find anything
and I've seen all of you live Dems at
the front nodding and going yeah it
wasn't really anything yeah let's ring
fence it let's pretend it's just some
administrative problem I I wish over lib
dams would go away and and read and read
the lock and John Stuart Mill and try
and remember what your party is meant to
be about because
listen I'm sorry
oh yeah go on then walk out
go on courageous Gary leave the room
farewell do you want me to come out and
have a fight with you Gary in Kansas
councilor Swain councilor Taylor please
return we will go
on each route and Branch change he
should not be sitting there you should
not be sitting there I'm sorry we cannot
you we're on this on the standards
committee you have been corrupt since
the day you started you should not be
here
I moved
it was nice
well done good luck in May
I move that we go to a show of hands
vote on the amendment but
doors
[Music]
five people it's recorded vote
okay thank you
we go to recorded votes please Trish
[Music]
Council Bill event
Council colclough
councilor con it
councilor Cox
councilor doors
Council Dewhurst
Council foden
Council look up and Bradbury
Council griddle
councilor Haynes councilor Hayes
councilor Gordon hook
councilor Jackie hook
councilor Jeffrey
that's the Janks
Council Keeling councilor McGregor
councilor Malone
is that for you chair councilor Milo um
is that an abstention or no vote
that's the Nutley
councilor Parker
councilor patch
um
that's up yet
counselor Patrick
councilor Purser Council rolleston
Russell councilor Swain
councilor Taylor
councilor Wrigley
councilor yourself chair against and
cancer Cath
I moved then that we go to the
recommendations as put forward proposed
by councilor connect
who also proposed a recorded vote for
that in in favor or against the his
recommendation
recommendations
so we are voting on the uh I think it
was 10 recommendations Advanced by
councilor connect either for or against
recorded vote please truth
councilor Austin
councilor Bradford
councilor colclough councilor Connor
Council Cox
councilor doors
cancer Dewhurst
cancer foden
Council government
councilor Gribble or councilor Haynes
councilor Hayes
councilor Gordon hook
councilor Jackie hook
councilor Jeffrey councilor Jenks
Council Keeling
councilor McGregor
councilor Malone
no voucher
Council Nutley
that's a Parker
counts the patch
again again I'm not sure whether I
should be taking part in this boat and I
would rather not have my name alongside
those um who I hold and have to disdain
please request majority please record no
vote thank you
cancer Pat
sopathic
that's the person Council rolleston
councilor Russell councilor Swain
Council Taylor
counselor Wiggly yourself chair for and
faster
uh that I think concludes the business
of the meeting on the agenda so I
declare the meeting closed